alors il y a une petite frange j'ai pas
aimé je ne voulais pas qu'on me prenne
pour un c'est quelque chose qui m'aurait
blessé je peux comprendre que non non
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà bientôt deux ans que Céline Dion a
mis sa carrière entre parenthèses à
cause d'un grave problème de santé cette
semaine nous avons appris que la star a
été hospitalisée et suit un traitement
expérimental pour guérir de ce mal qui
parfois la paralyse les fans du monde
entier prient pour que ce traitement de
la dernière chance sauve la diva pour
qu'un jour elle puisse remonter sur
scène elle a ce truc de STIF là de quoi
le truc de Steve peut dégénérer un
cancer d'accord
il faut redoser moi j'aimerais savoir
comment elle va vraiment est-ce que la
tournée quand je parle à Jacky Lombard
elle me dit enfin elle la fera jamais
elle est malade elle vit seule son fils
s'est barré elle est dans une maison
seule elle prend quand même mais vous
l'avez dit des anxiolytiques
c'est pas le temps qui va bien quand
même il y a un moment on dit la vérité
une femme qui a été très mal il y a
maintenant un an et demi un an et demi
qui peut à peu redevient dans un état de
santé tout à fait correct simplement
effectivement oui elle a dit secret
défense sur ma santé
vous faites marré parce que j'ai regardé
une interview en fait vous répondez à
toutes les questions il y a pas de tabou
il y a pas de pudeur il y a des sons il
y a quelques années qui vous demandent
et qui commence c'est lui Philippe
quelle est la taille de ton sexe et vous
répondez 18 cm
mais ça c'est parce que il y avait Rocco
Siffredi moi je voulais pas le vexer oui
mais sauf que vous êtes là qui répond à
ça
[Applaudissements]
qui me purge
tu vas chez Ardisson
et n'importe quoi alors vous continuez
vous dites ma femme est saoulée je suis
addict au sexe j'ai besoin de faire
l'amour tous les jours
pourquoi j'ai dit ça ouais parce que
c'est la vérité
ah ça c'est la petite phrase que j'ai
pas aimé vous avez dit j'ai gratté dans
une fille dans une cité avec une famille
modeste et c'était très dur de faire du
partage vis-à-vis de mes amis je ne
voulais pas qu'on prenne pour ces
quelque chose qui m'aurait blessé
je peux comprendre que non non mais
[Applaudissements]
alors il faut repartir j'avais huit ans
on est en 78 d'accord on est dans une
période où effectivement moi je vis j'ai
une sœur de frère à la maison ça parle
plus et terreau machin et tout ça donc
on est éduqué dans cette façon de vivre
et quand à chaque fois qu'on disait que
je faisais du patinage en traitait de
ou tarlos et quand on le disait ça
tu dis bah non le patin sport viril
c'est super compliqué il va essayer de
faire un accès et puis après on en
reparle souvent
quelqu'un vous disait par exemple tiens
je crois que Philippe qu'on est l'euro
est gay ça vous heurterait déjà ça
m'inquiéterait parce que je n'en serait
pas aperçu
mais aujourd'hui en fait
comment on a la possibilité peut-être de
tout essayer sans avoir sans que
personne est un avis sur ce que tu as
choisi de faire
j'ai peut-être peut-être que si j'avais
si j'avais eu l'opportun de vos enfants
si on rapporte le truc 30 ans en arrière
d'aujourd'hui avec le mytho avec tout ça
peut-être que je me serais laissé tenter
j'en sais rien non t'es pas si elle vous
enfant est gays aujourd'hui ça vous
posera vraiment ça me pose pas aucun
problème
en même temps j'ai que des filles
[Rires]
selon vous quel est l'animatrice du PAF
la plus sexy Lemarchand j'aime bien
ok ça roule physiquement en tous les cas
après
il est bon lui
la croises en fait
je pense
ce qui est dommage ça va pas être le
physique en fait ah c'est dommage
d'accord donc belle mais pas sympa
inégale
pas toujours pareil
annulation de la tournée de la Star
Academy en fait jamais été envisagée la
saison était trop courte et c'était un
trop gros risques donc c'est un peu des
gens dans people qu'on dit des bêtises
entre temps on a eu Jean-Louis blot on a
eu un bémol la prochaine il y en aura
une mais en fait elle n'a jamais été
envisagée attends ils ont tous signé
dans la maison de disque Léa c'est Sony
Louis aussi
et excusez-moi Léa elle a été prise dans
une maison de production de musique où
il y a Vitaa
elle cartonne c'est un carton
la réforme des retraites n'en finit plus
de diviser le pays
[Musique]
et l'Assemblée nationale sur le
fondement de l'article que
43 de la Constitution
en conservant tout le monde cette
épineux sujet s'invite dans tous les
débats et certaines personnalités
publiques n’hésitent plus à prendre la
parole dans les médias pour évoquer leur
retraite j'ai une toute petite retraite
entre 1500 et 2000 euros par mois à
l'image d'Herbert Léonard d'autres stars
se sont plaintes de leur petite pension
l'acteur Gérard Jugnot aurait selon ses
dires une petite retraite par rapport à
ce qu'il a donné alors que la chanteuse
Stone et l'animatrice Daniel Gilbert ont
révélé avoir elle aussi des petites
retraites vous avez combien de pensions
par mois un peu plus de 1000 euros
est-ce que vous avez juste une belle
retraite Daniel non l'argent que j'avais
devant moi mais je le dépense maintenant
d'accord mais je continue à chanter pour
toujours gagner un peu d'argent j'ai une
question
à vous poser
on parle de la pénibilité du travail
bien sûr il y a des gens qui sont des
déménageurs j'en ai vu à 40 ans ils ont
plus de dos et tout ça et tout ça mais
quand j'avais parié j'ai parlé à Jacky
Lombard qui a la grandeur des inconnus
des stars elle me dit Justin Bieber il
est burn out Céline Dion elle monte plus
sur scène on les preste tellement pour
des pour des concerts il y a une vraie
pénibilité aussi les mecs ils sont
rincés est-ce que dans un sens vous
pensez que pour les interprètes comme
vous il aurait pu avoir aujourd'hui vous
allez chanter pardon vous avez eu des
problèmes physiques apportées vous avez
78 ans et vous allez chanter pour gagner
votre vie c'est un métier c'est pas un
métier facile oui c'est pas un métier
pénible non plus ah non non c'est juste
qu'il faut savoir dès le début à ceux
qui nous regardent mettez de côté
exactement il faut savoir il faut savoir
ce qu'on fait il faut savoir ne pas
aller trop loin je pense que toutes ces
stars que dans Jackie Lombard vous
apparaît ce sont des des stars qui sont
press és comme des citrons